it may or may not surprise you
that the texas sheriff who is now
conducting a criminal investigation into
the ron desantis martha's vineyard
migrant stunt which i told you about
yesterday is now receiving death threats
vice has a very good article about this
by paul blest texas sheriff
getting death threats after saying he'd
investigate desantis for migrant plane
stunt
this is the party of law and order
remember
the people who are issuing the death
threats so the way it went is as follows
ron desantis had the bright idea to use
florida taxpayer money to fly
48 migrants awaiting asylum decisions
from texas
to martha's vineyard an island off the
coast of massachusetts with a very small
population and limited resources
we learned after this took place that
the migrants were lied to they were
lured there with false promises of jobs
and other things
this led to questions as to whether this
was even legal what ron desantis did or
might qualify as human trafficking we
now have lawyers who are representing
the migrants who have filed a civil suit
we will talk about that on the bonus
show and we have this texas sheriff
named javier salazar
who is criminally investigating desantis
i told you about that yesterday
the
texas sheriff said i'm going to
investigate this it seems that these
individuals were lured and that crimes
took place
and now he has received and his office
have received quote numerous threats
on tuesday a spokesperson told vice news
there have been numerous threats an
influx of calls to our dispatch and
administrative offices along with
hateful emails received
additionally as in any instance when our
office receives threats precautionary
measures will be made for safety of all
personnel
these are the people who claim to be for
law and order they are cheering the
possibly illegal stunt of luring
migrants to martha's vineyard but they
claim to be for law and order they are
then threatening the guy investigating
the possible criminality that took place
it is wild to see these law and order
people
losing their minds
after calling themselves the party of
law and order for decades and saying
comply with law enforcement
let them do their work well that's what
sheriff salazar is trying to do
and now they're threatening his life and
the life of officers that work in his
office and and remember
this is only over the investigative
process there hasn't even been any
indictment or charges and that this is
related to the trump stuff as well
the magats
are going bonkers merely over the fact
that trump is being investigated
understand that the search warrant
execution is part of the investigative
phase we haven't gotten to the
indictment part we don't have any
charges yet and it remains to be seen
whether we will
even the investigation is enough to get
them to abandon the very law and order
that they cling to
almost religiously when it's a tool or a
cudgel with which they can attack the
left and attack democrats
what's important here
to the trumpest law enforcement officers
and the trumpest members of the military
but for the most part the law
enforcement officers
you should be aware
that these maga people as much as they
claim to support you right now
they will turn on you in an instant if
you don't support their level of
delusion 100
we saw it happen with the capitol police
oh back the blue thin blue line support
law enforcement fund the police all
lives matter all this different stuff
oh
wait all of a sudden the capitol police
were trying to stop the trumpists from
getting into the capital well write them
off we we mean support the police but
not those police
oh the fbi which is also uh law
enforcement
they did everything legally to execute a
search warrant at donald trump's home
well yeah i mean we back the blue but
not them i mean that's different they're
now they're they're becoming political
the principles don't matter they abandon
them whenever it is not convenient and
if you are in law enforcement they will
abandon you
if you don't live up to their delusional
expectations we'll have all the clips we
played here on our instagram which you
can find at david pakman show